and switched at death news submitted by
bone-in veggies that's so stupid like I
dislike a bone-in chicken but like seeds
in the veggies what it would have Nana
they're just they're just honey funny a
bone-in veggie is like eating the care
with the [ __ ] stem ting on it a woman
said she mistakenly took a stranger off
of life support house how does she
mistakenly thought it was her mom for
some oh my god she meant to take her mom
but then the same name was your nurse Oh
Lord
so she's just pointed yep let's do it
and it's not even her mom no damn so
first of all she had a plug in her
iPhone when she target ah thank God yeah
shaking in the having quiet I'm trying
to watch my Netflix yeah so this one's
pretty crazy
so this try me place in New York
Shraddha me
Hawaii keep shaking try me this woman is
Brooklyn woman she was grieving for nine
days at the bedside of a brain-damaged
man who doctors insisted was her brother
what was she doing for nine days
grieving breathing all the way shouldn't
recognize her brother but it was
actually a stranger with the exact same
name
I didn't you realize that she's never
even had a brother so oh my god that'd
have been [ __ ] funny dude
rather why how was my brave girl imagine
she's white he's black that's my brother
yeah of Cole's no so what does hey Gina
that I bought these can't happen oh [ __ ]
you're right cut damn it
cancel Gina Gina was so insensitive
about multicultural families no so she
said that when she approached okay so
first of all the hospital when this man
arrived at the hospital he had his
social security card on him which said
Freddie Clarence Williams mm-hmm 14 he's
40 years old it know so he that is his
name okay um but and so like the
hospital looked at the records to see if
there's anyone that's ever been admitted
with the same name and this woman it
just so happens that her brother whose
name is Frederick Williams with no
middle name who's also the age 40 he was
admitted at that hospital way before so
then they contacted like his family
which is hurt right so then um she
approached him this man who he had a
drug overdose so he was unconscious and
like brain-dead he had tubes in his
mouth and a neck brace and he was really
swollen but she resembled his brother he
resembled her brother so they were just
like well then I guess this is him
because she hadn't heard from her actual
brother and if he stolen they look like
completely different people
you never did drugs ever like
thank you later it's like no wonder I
knew it wasn't you the thing is like
when you smell different when there's
when her sister came to the hospital
room to see this man she was like that's
not my brother and then but then she got
closer and then doctors were like no yes
it is
your brother and whatever and then like
even the first sister she was like yeah
her brother whatever and then that's
when the second sister was like oh okay
I guess I mean I guess yeah also there's
multiple sisters there's two that I know
of they're both grieving for their non
brother exactly this man or like their
brother has two daughters who's 17 and
18 years old but they live in Virginia
so they went over to Brooklyn to say
goodbye to their daughter to their
father because the sister had approved
of taking him off life support because
they the doctors told her like there's
nothing else we can do for him like he's
brain-dead well weird a real daughter's
did the daughters go that's not my dad
where's the real dude at the real dad so
hold on so then after the fake brother
was taken off life support they took him
to the more you did an autopsy on him
and everything and that's when they
found out like that's when they told her
like oh my bad this isn't your brother
so they just killed somebody oh yeah she
like signed an approval Oh killing his
brother be real brother what's that
hospitals in trouble there yeah
so the real brother he was actually in
jail this whole time
that's why I bathe didn't hear from him
oh and that brothers mad it's like you
gonna take me off a lobster it was like
you were gonna kill me but then she
explained like wait the doctor said like
there's nothing I could do whatever and
then so he was like okay fine
like oh that's cool that's cool that's
cool yeah he was like this though you
were gonna take me off what if I wanted
to live a fulfilling life all bad
okay you steel cup - I don't know
thirties Great Depression but the
stripes on he had like a ball and chain
on his [ __ ] rocks yeah that's what
happens no but yeah the medical
examiner's office they call it the
family just in time because they were
planning they weren't doing the funeral
it would have paid for a whole ass
funeral for no one Wow a forest ranger
what what about the people who lost
their [ __ ] simply yeah so that's the
thing um she wanted to find out who the
real family was so she could send my
condolences like flowers or something I
kill them I'm sorry because she feels
horrible well she should it's not her
fault yeah it ain't her fault at all the
hospital or like whoever's in charge of
knowing that is [ __ ] so fiery they
wouldn't tell her because of privacy of
course they can't so that so did the
hospital contact the actual family well
you know it's crazy the hospital's like
there's no merit to this we did nothing
wrong oh there for a second your own ass
well yeah it's another suing they're
gonna be photo suing the family suing
the real family oh my god so much money
ah well I don't know anything about the
actual family of the man that died
there's nothing reporting about that
motion I would see things but yeah so
I'm talking about the sister the
mornings
oh okay security though emotional
distress rowdy you punch in that [ __ ]
social security number and then you can
match up the yeah and right well that we
only did it to their own Hospital
database yeah yeah that's what I [ __ ]
up though yeah for sure but they're
they're not they don't think that
they've looked at all oh dude he had a
middle someone died yeah and one thing
that her brother doesn't have up in the
Philippines we don't have middle name so
I don't know what happened
oh he looks just like you is the problem
looks just like you and luck she's
holding a photo of her album is [ __ ]
dude don't like great photo though
that's a really a photo
come on you also thought that he was
your brother karma we were all in this
together
yeah it's not our fault you don't
recognize your own but it's kind of
bittersweet right like it's unfortunate
that they pulled the plug on this
stranger but God you were just in jail I
was thinking it would be something
Nell's like he comes into the hospital
like damn did they one of our relatives
die you walk soon
that's so funny he's in jail dog yeah
it's like you wish that this guy's a
stand-up dude and then it's like
different and then he's in jail I did
all right best I'm a serial rapist up in
jail for 20 years but wait the people
for 20 and the point is his whole family
didn't know he was in jail how [ __ ] up
is that like was he in there for a few
days for a DUI charge or some light what
was it it was for an assault like he
does it so you just beat somebody up or
whatever
I know do you fall on a contact you said
not that I know of
cuz don't be they tell don't they tell
you like don't they tell your family or
whoever let you get your one call yeah I
don't know they didn't mention anything
about him not having connections with
his family like why they would not know
he even like I said he has two daughters
by the time he's brain dead like the
person was brain dead they you know
there was like low chance of them
staying and like being alive or being
ever back recovering so sight who cares
just pull the plug
no I'm curious but you know well it's
kind of nice for the other family
because if that relative was brain dead
and they did what they were too scared
to pull the plug somebody else did it
for them so technically they didn't have
to murder their own siblings somebody
else did it for them
well there's those families who are like
super religious - I would have
that's murder I don't think they've been
dead you're supposed to take a life
whatever Lu you taught me that's a lot
anybody else did so it kind of works out
like if some gal they go after her for
murder
yeah if they were brain dead that means
their soul left the body breathing yeah
I see it as like you know muscles they
[ __ ] still spaz after you die
or like rigor mortis and [ __ ] that's
just what I see that as unlike that eel
yeah I'm like if the brain is gone I
mean if their brain is done for they're
done they're they're already dead I do
that [ __ ] even like halfway through this
oh my legs just broken hey guys I
survived
the [ __ ] plug sir we got a [ __ ] she
can't even speak Joe it's okay it's just
a broken toe we gotta pull I wonder I
wonder if I would be able I think I
would I think I'd be able to pull the
plug I don't think I can because I don't
wanna suffer anymore I don't think I can
what about Oman anybody on your mom
anybody I told you guys this before but
I was there with my friend and his mom
was taken off life support it was you
don't have to pull the plug I got to
pull off all that that's that's harder
right that's harder it's like all right
there's a lot of chords it's like the
breathing - and everyone the finger nerd
they're helping yeah yeah I don't I feel
like I'm relieving them of pain that's
why it's like imagine if we were all
camping and [ __ ] and then like we got a
loss and it we're about to [ __ ] die
and to top it off a rattlesnake came up
and [ __ ] bit the [ __ ] out of us and
there is no chance of us rattlesnake do
we all wait till it's our turn you know
what happens this will got bit he took
the rattlesnake and he just [ __ ]
business
fine three to get back oh my god